I'm Jim Norton I'm about to answer the
Internet who's the one celebrity you
would want at your funeral Luke Perry
we'd rather have a good hand job from
your grandmother or a bad hand job from
your grandmother neither a good [ __ ]
from my grandmother
starting today if you get $10,000 a day
for every day you don't masturbate how
many days could you go without jerking
off a dollar fifty s worth whatever that
is would you rather sit on a cake and
eat a dick or sit on a dick and eat a
cake can I take both options
would you rather wake up to a [ __ ]
every morning or $100 under your pillow
every morning I take the hundred dollars
and spend it on a [ __ ] you can have
sex with anyone you want but they die
immediately after who do you have sex
with every one of my ex-girlfriends at
what age is it okay to let yourself go
for me it was 16 would you rather have a
dog's personality and a cat body where I
cat personality in a dog's body I don't
I'd rather blow someone in a bunny suit
at the end of the shining it's great for
anybody over 40 would you rather date a
girl who laughs at everything or nothing
everything does it means she's stupid
and she [ __ ] I would rather be blind or
[ __ ] I'd like to be both okay would
you rather know when you're going to die
or how you're going to die I'd rather
know Wayne cuz I already know how I'm
gonna hang myself we drive a ball by age
20 we're 5 3 with a full head of hair
[ __ ] I'd like to be bald by the age of
20 it's a really shitty unfunny answer
I actually considered that what a [ __ ]
boring piece of [ __ ] all kidding aside
let me weigh the options okay if you
could get one historical figure to have
a Twitter account who would it be
Hitler come on he'd be fun to retweet
would you rather sit down with your
parents and watch every sexual encounter
you've had or watch your parents sex
tape when they conceived you ha I'd
rather sit down and watch my own sexual
thing because I've already seen
Polaroids when they conceived me yeah
why my father took pictures yeah exactly
it was like looking through the Hubble
telescope and see in the beginning of
time but as my dad [ __ ] my mom from
the back if you had to win a game show
to stay alive which game show would you
choose does it mean the rest of the
contestants would die I have to say the
price is right if you could go back to
any period who would you want to go back
and party with Kurt Cobain on that last
day do you think there is more porn
stars or murderers in the world porn
stars yeah and the fact that people
can't [ __ ] them that's what makes
murderers did you take four million
dollars to be on catch a predator I was
already on it for free I know would you
rather have everyone naked all the time
where everyone closed all the time
everyone closed all the time what can I
make that can I actually amend that
everyone naked III would like to make
individual judges is that possible sure
all right bye wait okay what STD would
you be willing to have if you were what
the pass it on to your biggest enemy
AIDS Jesus Christ that's a no-brainer
would I pass Sam Roberts my radio
partner
okay